S
MIOT STATE CIT AFTERE MINNA SENE
PASSED ONE OF THREE LLO
LEGISLATURESCRNORM
LEAST 417 ANTIILLS
HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED SO FAR THIS
IT'S A NEW RECORD. OIR
NEARLY T TRANSGENDERPEOPLE IN TN
TRANS ADULTS SAY BEEACING TO WT
SURVFEW WEEKS,
IDAHO'S GOVERNOL TRANSERFROM THT
ALIGN WIT THEIR GENDERIDENTIES.S
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO AND
HEALTH CARE FOR TRANSREON RETE
TENNESSEE A LSUIT TORANSGENDERHE
BLEGISLATUREEDS TO AN ACTBARRINF
TO HEALTHCARE S APUBERTY THAT
ONTANA HOUSE,
FIER LEGISLATO
ZOEY'S EFFTE LEGISLATORS VOTINGU
TRANSHI
PUBERTYEY ARE TRANS,
THAT IS TANTAMOUORE.
BESH
ONLYHI IS, IF IS. ONN  TIME THEN
CATION WHEN YOUOW IN
R HANDS? NOW THE
MONTANA FREEDOM CAUCUSCALLING F,
CLAIMING SHE TRIED TO SHAM THEEN
AK TO EFFORT ON  HOUSEAN
SINCE TUEAY IN NT ISALWAYSR OUR
UN IS THAT RATHER
THAN A FORMER CENTER, A FORMAL
CENTER HOUSE IS JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO REFUSE TO
SESSION, SO YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO
E ON ANY
GISLATIO AHOW DO P TO WORK AROUD
IT SPEAKER GEAR HAS STATEDHAT
ONNY LEGISLATION, REGARDSS
, AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS
I ECTED OBE
CONSTITUENTS TO COME HEREND
DEBATE BILND HAVE THE HARD
DISCUSSIONS AND T MYTY
ME TAT THE SPEAKEROE
O M. SOET'S TALK
ABHATECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I THINK THEONTANA
FR CAUCUSES ISU Y T TO SHAMLEGIA
YOU THINK THATTE AGAINST ALLOWIG
BTHUBERTY BLOCKER FEXAMPLE. WED
HAND I K A TRANS
RSHE JOY WALIVE WHEN WE ARE ALLN
THAT COM WITH ABLE
TO TRANSITION, ALSO IN TERMS OTE
PARENTS. TELL ME ABOUT SUICIDE F
THESE. THAT'S THAT S WHY I
HE ACCOULE FOR
IN IGNORANCE ANDOTOBVIOUSLYLOT Y
QUESTION. WHAT MHT YOU SAY TO
SOMEBODY WHO SAYSOOJUST ISN'T EE
, S OU KNOW,
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY, AN
WOULD MESENDYEGRETS, ANDRETHAT .
PERSON WOUAY AND
FOREMOST, WE ACKNOWLEDGEMEOTHERY
F M
AND MAJOR MEDICALCIATION SAYS TR
CARRTIFE SA FOR TRANS
PEOPLE, ANDO
BE A DNSDOWN THE ME PERSONEGRETY
LINE.OOK AT SOMETHING LIKE
KNEE SURGERIES THAT HAVE HUGE
REGR RE FOR
TRANSITION IS MINIMAL. THE GREAT
TE AFFIRMING
SURGERIE THAN 1%AV K IT. WE
KNOW IT REDUCES SUICIDALITY. WE
EGT. MSCARES IMPORTANTED. SO INL
TRYING TO SSGENDE
HEALTHCARE, THBL
18. THEREOKE. FROM PEOPLE U
PREVENT ANYONE,  FGECCKIND OFURG
IN MISSOURS WEEK. I'M S FOCUSEDT
SAW IT OR NOT, BUT THE
REPUBLICAN ATTORNEY GENERAL ISTG
I THE F S
TONDER
SECRETARYS.M IN HIS
DON'ROFT VERY CONSERVATIVEBLICAS
. BUT HE SAID, I WOULDN'TYHIS BS
GETTING I AND I THOUGHT THATTERH
THE  PROGRESSED
. THE ATTACK ON TRANS
RIGHTS BEGANITH ATTPT TO
LIMIT TRATHLETES,
AND AS WE'RE SEEIN THAT BEGIN AE
FEDE LELL, AND TO STRIP TRANSPEH
MICHAEL KNOWLES SAID, ELITE PPLE
GONNA STOP WITH A SPORTSMAL IS S
PEOPLE'S ACCESSTHE CARE WE
NEED, ANDHA WHY YOUESEEINGE STAN
, BUT TH LOOKING TO MO AT. WHATT
OMHE UM FORLD
THE ATTACKS ARENTIN